[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the first girl will make love oh god sex
right yeah where i go do you want a warm
towel
because i nutted all over her back or
whatever a warm towel
yeah because i do that with ladies i'm a
gentleman i'll go get like a dish rag or
something
but how do you make it warm i put the
heat like some faucet i have
hot water oh yeah leave hot water in the
house
yeah i'll strain it i'll give them that
and then they they'll wipe their back or
whatever right yeah yeah
she's the first one that said no you
want a warm towel she goes no i don't
know
first you want to hold each other no for
starters he doesn't have a very
um far um ejaculation trajectory
on anyone's back not in a million years
it kind of is this tiny little dollop
that just weeps out of his dick
and you know that's true i have old calm
i'm an old guy
they're fat there's no power there's
none of that this is what the people
want
so so it basically is a sad drool
it's yeah it's it just weeps out it goes
and hasn't changed in the time it
doesn't make
no you don't i know
let's start there i mean first of all
you have real reasons with the japanese
let's get into them for a little bit
yeah well um well the japanese you know
they oppressed our people for like 50
years
and um they stole our rice yeah
you don't steal the right you don't
steal the rice that's [ __ ] up when you
steal the rice it's [ __ ] up
yeah and you know what asians we love it
we don't know what it is about it
are they it's small and not cute
they're not your least favorite though
yeah so what my dad told you know my dad
told me a story once
i don't know if this is true or not yeah
but he told me
one day um right before i went to sleep
i was maybe eight
because do you know what japanese used
to do to us
i go no because i'm a kid yeah and
you're like eight i'm eight
and you're like lollipop they used to
hang according on
by the angle with the rope
i go oh it's like a reverse you can't
die that way right
right it's like a reverse hanging yeah
like we used to do you're like for fun
yeah yeah that sounds fun yeah no he
goes no no no no no
they from a tree i go oh but below
they take a big big pot
of boiling water boiling water
i go uh and i'm sleeping like this yeah
because
then they dunk they don't put it on him
and we come out right they don't cause
every time lay your skin go on ah
right and he goes good night
good night father how come you don't see
many asian people with down syndrome
and now you're i'm going to answer it
with the most racist thing
because you're setting me up to say
something racist racist
scientific i'm going to answer this to
you right sometimes you can't tell with
koreans
you wanna [ __ ] with my money huh okay
we have the same amount as you white
people
it's just that sometimes you just can't
okay and if that if you wanted me to say
that
you set me up right and so everyone
listens right now
yeah you know what you're doing wait
what are you saying you're saying what
i'm saying what kind of people
what kind of people what koreans are
look like
what they look like what down syndrome
people right so basically here's how
this is what happened right she wants to
say that
i don't she wants to see that i don't
want to she can't so i don't want to she
has success
so the i say it and then she can go
there we go
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] you and you're a
little racist with that bruce lee
sweatshirt but that's fine
dude this is it's not it's not is that
for bobby no
i just really you know no you're not
chinese korean
offensive look roots of fight who i'm a
big fan of
sent a whole bunch you saw those boxes i
think this is an unconscious thing on
tom's part
no just to bruce lee we had all the
other muhammad ali
you had a you think i should go change
alan iverson and and you picked out the
bruce i think it's a little i like you
conscious decision maybe because you
know that bob
is coming here yeah yeah
is this should i change it no no you're
fine with it i like it i think
i think you um are trying to make me
feel comfortable
and i think that that's like you're
going out of your way to make me feel
good
this is a perfect segue first of all i'm
not gonna forget that uh
meth gets your dick hard okay if you had
any kind let's talk about
problems i'm here to tell you forget
that viagra forget about southwest
forget about dick and
plants and all that stuff yeah so i
don't know if you believe me or not
yeah but if you like to see me smoke
smith with a small
limp dick that doesn't get hard any
other way and watch it get harder and
harder the more i smoke
the harder my dick gets is that was that
your experience
yes wow you were 11. it doesn't matter
well let's talk
let's talk about the first time can we
talk about the first how does one how
does one procure
math smoke at the first time how did it
happen okay here we go okay
you want to go down memory line yes i'll
go down memory lanes
okay to you yeah number one
when i was in my late childhood am i
eight nine years old
when eight nine years old i was late
that's like yeah i was um practically an
adult
i was molested okay what
no yes oh okay when you were when you
were
89 i was molested by a guy with down
syndrome i do it in my act
goodness are you serious okay and then
my god is the guy i'm sorry
i don't in his 20s i'm over right [ __ ]
man it didn't bother me at the time
i don't think i don't really find your
story to be like a real molestation
i feel like it was like a barter a trade
system because you kept going back to
the same guy
yeah yeah you're right well that's how
they court you i mean i i
understand
[Music]
most importantly i have a question for
you being that you are asian both of you
is it possible is it even physically
possible
to get full eating sushi
[Music]
the way we eat it yeah now okay here's
what i'm here here's what i'm struggling
with
so i've been sushi shamed we both have
many times
so many times by both chefs and servers
well they're like that's too much food
and i'm being polite by not doing their
accent so they're
they'll say like that's enough just do
the accent
yeah yeah yeah yeah it just feels more
organic yeah
so it's too much food
oh my god they've actually been like
don't order this amount and i'm like
all right and then like you know start
like
are you still hungry yeah okay i'll play
you i'll play you play the
guy okay because i don't know what
you're saying okay excuse me ching chong
um
hey hey nobody that says that
nobody right
now yeah
[Music]
number three the boat i mean the boat
with all the sushi on
how many friends come with you
did you even say he knows what i said oh
my god
it was the most racist thing ever oh my
god i was so racist
that was the most racist asian accent
i've ever hurt my life what are you
talking about we gotta get out of here
that was dead
that was [ __ ] crazy so racist yeah
so your dad's temper was [ __ ] serious
oh bro dude
my brother my poor brother
my pro brother one time
my brother had a friend a black
friend kid anthony and
my brother's like i got this casio
keyboard anthony
is a gammon yeah spend the night so
anthony spends the night
and playing this cat
how old are they my brother might be 11
12. okay
oh you're the door open my dad
completely naked
completely naked
right anthony what the [ __ ] right
what the [ __ ] right my dad takes the
keyboard
slams it on my brother's [ __ ] back
keys are flying all over the place but
here's the thing
what we discovered he turns around
there's toilet paper sticking out of his
[ __ ]
jesus right right and that's when we
knew about his anal leakage
he had serious anal leakage and i have
it now too
yeah what cause is it genetic yeah i
think so yeah
i don't do the toilet paper what do you
do let it go
just [ __ ] oozes out yeah i have like
okay she hates cleaning clothes hates
cleaning my underwear
oh my god yeah because there's all these
stains and stuff
a lot of bad stains do you ever put like
a tampon or a pad in there or something
no i i don't like the it feels
uncomfortable when i'm walking around i
know it's there i think you should put a
pad in no i don't i don't think so
i think you should i i think that i
should do what my heart says and my
heart says i want to be free
and it's not like the mask and have like
shitty stained underwear
yeah but it's like you're gonna get a
stained [ __ ] tampon when you're down
there
yeah but this way you're i'm trying to
argue this
yeah yeah yeah it's a losing argument
yeah yeah yeah you're right i'm not
gonna do it you're not gonna do it and
is it a lot of leakage
like on the car white right
i almost didn't make it today let's just
say that really yeah
i'm still like if you see my underwear
right now
if you see me under right now you would
be like i don't i can't even believe you
showed up to this
is that brown bad i mean when i when i
came in here i go i need to use your
bathroom immediately
do you have one please and so that
that's that'll give you
you made a big brown in there
i wouldn't say uh big is um
not the right word i would use what
would you use messy
and i've done god's work yeah right no
gay
i mean just not doing gay things shrimp
what no no shrimp no shrimp yeah no
shrimps
leviticus yeah i've been uh i've been um
i try to give as much as i can
you're a giving guy yeah and i want to
be spiritual you know so
people can listen to me right now i'm a
heathen that's fine
no they're not but you know what one can
repent and one can change his
behavior why would you feel bad though
it's not your fault your parents weren't
on the
listen let me tell you something my kid
doesn't take a dump for a day and i'm
all over him
if your parent doesn't know that you're
smoking meth and you're out in the
streets and you're doing stuff that's on
them man they should have had an eye on
you
yeah it's not your responsibility would
you like how do you feel oh my god you
can't let it go
yeah as a guy you're like i know what i
like so you have like certain skills
right well
that's silly i just want to say this to
you and i'm not going to go into detail
about it okay
but when you're young you don't know
what you like
yeah so i think it was pretty much
amateur hour okay
you know i mean i would probably like i
wouldn't go down to the sack or the
taint
yeah right and go you like that
right i think it was more like you know
licking the tip and going you know you
know is that suffice
right what it's just funny
make sure you be tired
you feel good yeah like if i was
but look how happy this is never this
joyful yeah
if i was never a gay man yeah and i was
and you were gay and you and i were
having sexual
sexualities with each other you and i
would probably be like um we probably
know what we
we liked you know of course and we would
do extra things
you know yeah to to please ourselves
sure
i would like to please you thanks yeah
you're welcome i like that but yeah he
was a kid babe
yeah kids don't know how to give blow
jobs in case you're wondering
i mean were you blowing
[Music]
so check this out this guy yeah smoked
mess
with his brother something cool happened
my brother didn't believe me but when he
smoked with me he put out his dick i
couldn't believe how big his dick was
he jacked off in four strokes and shot
the most [ __ ] he's ever shot
and he's fine he has no drop problems at
all yeah
his dick gets even harder and thicker
and even more calm he
leaves me now
this is a pretty good ad for meth i
think right yeah
yeah so he was 50 when you started
dating
i remember that and then so holy [ __ ]
he lied on his tinder profile too he
said he was 36
when he was actually 42.
but you could wikipedia him and find out
all the truths
but i think his birthday is wrong on his
wikipedia too oh what's his like sexual
strength
oh tom you [ __ ] bastard you
know what my strengths are i bet i don't
know i i have none
you know for somebody who is really um
eccentric in real life he's actually
he's a square kind of a square he's a
square
he's very he's a missionary type of guy
okay look
okay look at okay let me say something
okay he did
there's a listen okay this is et's
finger
right okay it's been she stuck this
right in
my anus that's awesome without asking
with permission
i felt like it wasn't asking no or you
weren't clear about what you're doing
you're like choo-choo
or whatever making a noise i definitely
asked okay i'm a woman
this thing went in there right and i'm
not into it did it on stage but it was
really true where i would be like
you know when you're a kid a boy you use
some fascination with like
guns and things right and i would ask
him these things and he'd be
very like not really and then i know my
dad was in the marine corps i knew he
fought in vietnam so then i was like
seeing movies and i'd be like what was
that like he's like well you know i was
lieutenant really wasn't like
blah blah blah year after year i'd be
like
did you kill people in war and he was
like it wasn't like that when you're
lieutenant you're in charge of the
platoon
and i was like okay yeah and then like
this story i was like you don't have
like any stories from being in a [ __ ]
war yeah and then like
like now he'll be like you just don't
understand how good it feels when you
see the enemy just blown apart
you know
oh my god he told me first of all a few
years ago we talked about throwing
grenades into bunkers
and then just last week he was like i go
so throwing a you know he's like yeah
one of my guys threw a grenade
and it was defective so it blew up and
it killed him and i was like [ __ ]
i go did you ever throw grenades he's
like yeah so what we would do is we'd
throw a grenade into like a bunker
and it would shock people and then we
would uh
throw the tnt in there with like a i
forget how he described it he goes
there's no one left after that
[Laughter]
cool i'll subdue him in a second just
pat him this side of the belly he's calm
again
so it's like you have a pug you have
like a
[Music]
yeah yeah and then all i also um um i
smell
tell him how i smell you actually he
doesn't have
my feet oh yeah well we know about your
feet we don't even
know it's just it's just green and
full of fun my left foot my left foot
you know how daniel day-lewis did a
movie called my left foot yeah they
should do a remake with my foot
it's green and full of food it's not
even that it's it's it's a
studio 54. but it's not that he doesn't
want to fix it like it partied
yeah yeah you know
he we have the medication that actually
works for it but
um when it started to work efficiently
he wasn't into that he wanted a hobby
his left foot is his hobby he wants
something to scratch at night
he likes the itch he likes scratching
the itch and the satisfaction from that
feeling yeah is this hold on has this
replaced the
glue behavior are we still getting naked
and playing video games all of those
things just that now the foot is the
eighth hobby
okay do you feel like you're great
you're a caretaker
of something oh yeah you do so i was
born in san diego right
seoul south korea i understand the
capital okay so
that's crazy was it near the dmz like
tell me a little more about it
have you been to seoul now no i don't
know i've been there yeah i've been
there i did a um
um a long like eight years ago i get a
call
from a korean guy yep hey he goes
hey and i go what's up how'd you get my
number
if no people i know people that's what
it says
yeah i know people i know people and i
go okay so what's up my name is jyp
you know what jyp is he's like the puff
daddy
of korea right so he
like um all those you know blm what
bts and uh all right right right blm's a
little different
yeah he loves blm that's joy jyp
so you're talking about like the
producer you're talking yeah
so you're talking about the huge uh pop
groups right the korean pop he calls me
this guy right
here and he goes hey you do music videos
so what the [ __ ] i go what do the music
videos you want to do it
and i go do what music video who are you
googling me google me says i google them
right
oh [ __ ] this guy's legit so i call him
back what's that dog
yeah yeah yeah so he flew me out there
jesus yeah so he flew my brother and i
out there i go
um he goes out
i give it to the client
[Music]
just the wrong way